albon soir que l'once maison merci
d'être avec nous est ce qu'on peut
parler ce soir de réelles pas en avant
pour l'avenir de l'accord de vienne est
une possible reprise des discussions
c'est manifestement un succès pour
monsieur grossi le directeur général de
l'agencé internationale de l'énergie
atomique et qui siège à vienne il a
obtenu de son interlocuteur iranien mais
nouveau chef de l'agencé nucléaire
iranienne nommé par le gouvernement au
gouvernement en effet que les les
inspecteurs de l'aiea puisse tenir très
régulièrement faire la maintenance de
leurs caméras de leur matériel de
surveillance changer les disques durs
lorsque c'est nécessaire mais comme on
l'a dit dans votre sujet ils n'auront
pas pour autant accès au contenu des
enregistrements
le contenu des enregistrements c'est
lorsque l'accord de 2015 fonctionnera à
nouveau et lorsque les états unis et les
autres pays
respecteront leurs engagements et que et
que l'iran rentrera aussi dans le cadre
de ses engagements donc c'est un sur le
plan technique c'est un accord limité je
crois que c'est important sur le plan
humain parce que ça veut dire que les
inspecteurs de la u avant régulièrement
aller dans les installations nucléaires
iraniennes qu'ils vont nouer des
contacts que le directeur général
lui-même va retourner régulièrement en
iran et discuter avec les responsables
politiques et ça je crois que c'est une
une chose extrêmement positive quel est
l'enjeu de l'intervention de ses
inspecteurs de l'aiea sur l'équipement
nucléaire est ce qu'on doit s'attendre à
quelque chose de différent précède cet
accord pas vraiment puisque c'est un
geste de bonne volonté que fait le
nouveau gouvernement
iranien ce geste est tout bénéfice pour
lui puisque le goûte pas grand chose les
inspecteurs n'ont pas accès au contenu
des enregistrements mais enregistrements
seront faits et stocker jusqu au jour où
au miracle l'accord sera à nouveau en
vigueur alors effectivement ils l'ont
fait les viera lien pour marquer qu'eux
ils étaient prêts à poursuivre la
négociation et que ce gouvernement dans
tout le monde dit qu'il est beaucoup
plus dur que le précédent puisqu'on les
faits les élections du 18 juin ont donné
un résultat favorable conservateur donc
aux gens beaucoup plus dur et ils
veulent montrer que ils veulent
continuer la négociation mais
naturellement il montre aussi que si les
négociations échouent en raison
notamment l'exigence américaine pour
rentrer dans l'accord eh bien ce ne sera
pas de leur fait ce sera la
responsabilité des américains les
américains veulent plus que l'accord de
2015 alors que les iraniens veulent un
retour à l'accord de 2015 purement et
simplement en échange de la levée des
sanctions occidentales enfin des
sanctions qui ont été mises à lorsque
les américains sont sortis de l'accord
c'est pour ça qu'ils le font c'est ça
l'intérêt de l'iran que la pression
internationale retombe et les sanctions
avec bien sûr ils veulent que les
sanctions soient levés et elodie
d'ailleurs le les sanctions sont très
très brutal
l'économie est exsangue
la population souffre beaucoup c'est pas
pour autant qu'elle se soulève contre le
régime la preuve est là les lieux des
gens plus conservateur que précédemment
donc les sanctions ne perd pas comme les
auteurs des sanctions auraient souhaité
qu'elle opère et en fait effectivement
le gouvernement et le vendeur de lever
ses sanctions mais il veut pas payer
trop cher il veut revenir purement et
simplement dans ses engagements 2
2 juillet 2015 pas plus ce que demandent
en plus et américains c'est qu'on
mentionne dans la reprise de l'accord
que les sujets balistiques sont
maintenant très important qu'il faudra
en discuter et que aussi le rôle que
joue l'iran dans la région à travers ces
milices pro iranienne donc les
ingérences dans les affaires intérieures
des pays voisins soit un sujet qu'ils
puissent faire l'objet de discussions
d'ailleurs les iraniens ne sont pas cons
entre discuter ces sujets a simplement
ils veulent pas que ça figure dans le
nouvel accord alors vous restez c'est
avec mon si vous le voulez bien que de
blanche maison puisqu'on vend évoqué
ensemble un autre sujet d'actualité sur
le front du nucléaire si l'iran on l'a
vue semble qu'au père et la corée du
nord en revanche elle ne compte pas non
plus réduire son programme nucléaire qui
en auraient testé avec succès un nouveau
missile de croisière à longue portée
c'est ce qu'a annoncé hier soir l'agencé
officielle nord-coréenne le pays
continue donc ses essais d'armes
tactique malgré les sanctions
internationales
le japon s'est dit aujourd'hui très
préoccupé dans un communiqué le
pentagone a dit de son côté dénoncé un
développement continu par la corée du
nord de son programme nucléaire donc il
n'y a rien qui concède à son troisième
lancement
pourquoi ces nouveaux tirs déjà les
résolutions de l'onu interdisent à la
corée du nord de faire des tirs
balistiques mais elles n'interdisent pas
de faire des essais sur des fusées
je crois de croisière des missiles de
croisière qui le vol à très basse
altitude qui d'ailleurs sont difficiles
à repérer pour cette raison alors que
les missiles balistiques vont au delà de
l'atmosphère et qu'on peut les repérer
beaucoup plus facilement d'ailleurs les
américains comme les sud coréens ont dit
qu'il n'avait pas repéré ces tirs ils
ont été annoncés très calmement par l'
agence de la corée du nord dans la
journée d'aujourd'hui alors les japonais
sont très inquiet parce que la portée de
ces tirs d'après l'agencé nord coréenne
ces 1500 km ça veut dire que l'essentiel
du territoire du japon pourrait être
touchée par des missiles de croisière de
ce type donc le japon veut se protéger
par un bouclier antimissile très
efficace et les discussions déjà très
ancienne avec les américains à ce sujet
la corée du sud est très embarrassée
parce que elle reçoit demain monsieur
wang le ministre des affaires étrangères
de la chine et peut-être qu'on peut se
demander d'ailleurs si les coréens du
nord n'ont pas choisi cette date pour
embarrasser la chine pour la mettre au
pied du mur puisque la chine
traditionnellement protège c'était lié à
un commode qui est la corée du nord et
bien que va-t-elle répondre aux
questions de la corée du sud qui est
pour elle un partenaire économique très
important alors en tout cas un
washington dénonce justement un des
menaces vous parliez des voisins pesant
sur les voisins de la corée du nord et
la communauté internationale est ce
qu'on peut
s'attendre à des détériorations une
détérioration des relations
diplomatiques entre la corée du nord et
les etats-unis qui s'étaient réchauffées
an plus tôt avec donald trump alors la
corée du nord n'a pas de relations
diplomatiques avec beaucoup de pays mais
en effet donald trump avait bien qu'il
ait pas rétabli à 100 diplomatique près
initiative très spectaculaire qui était
d'aller négocier tout seul pratiquement
sans aucune préparation avec kim jong-un
et ça a donné les résultats que l'on
connaît c'est à dire que ça n'a pas
marché en réalité on pas bien que
d'abord il ya deux situations politiques
probablement difficile à pyongyang avec
un problème de succession qui se profile
on parle beaucoup de la soeur de kim
jong il de kim jong-un pardon qui
apparemment joue un rôle politique
important et qui se verrait bien dans la
rolls rôle de la de la succession de de
kim jong-un bon je crois que en effet là
la tendance va être de renforcer les
sanctions puisque la corée du nord
poursuit dans une voie belliqueuse
est-ce que c'est ces essais sont
fréquents en corée du nord et qu'est-ce
qu'ils veulent montrer qu est ce qu il
veut le dire ils ont toujours une
signification qu une situation politique
d'abord le le le timing est toujours
très important et on voit où on voit
bien derrière voulait voler des images
impressionnantes ont le sens de la
communication effectivement du régime
nord-coréen voilà et la même n'hésite
pas à mettre dans l'embarras alors leur
principal protecteur la chine puisque la
date a été choisie pour cela et donc
tous les essais nucléaires les effets
magnifique et maintenant les missiles de
croisière sont toujours faits à des
dates précises pour répondre à une
préoccupation politique là c'était aussi
pour répondre à des manoeuvres qui avait
eu lieu dans avec la corée
l'autre l'accord et ses alliés dans les
mers voisine est naturellement à chaque
fois qu'il ya des manoeuvres militaires
impliquant la corée du sud la corée du
nord fait un test années ces quelques
quel qu'il soit pour démontrer qu'elle
est là est en effet sans doute pour dire
moi je veux je suis prêt à discuter mais
à discuter
de façon réaliste c'est à dire je veux
qu'on garantisse l'existence de l'état
corée du nord pour le moment celle armes
nucléaires qui ma meilleure garantie il
faut me donner une autre garantie et
parmi celles ci la dénucléarisation de
la presqu'île coréenne merci claude
havelange faisons nous avoir apporté
votre éclairage